[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAY: I am delighted
to welcome you
and to welcome Dr.
John Hume, our guest,
for the third Ford/MIT
Nobel Laureate Lecture.
The Nobel Prize
recognizes contributions
of uncommon excellence and
impact in a variety of fields.
Dr. Hume's Peace Prize in 1998
is in that great tradition.
I'm also delighted to
acknowledge the Ford Motor
Company for its support of
this lecture series, that
aims to bring the very best
thinking on great issues
to the MIT community.
We are also grateful for the
cooperation of the MIT Lecture
Series Committee,
the Graduate Student
Council, and the
Undergraduate Association.
A couple of
housekeeping matters.
After the lecture, Dr.
Hume will accept questions
from the audience.
And following the program,
we invite the audience
to a reception in the lobby
of the Student Center.
Finally, a future note.
On Tuesday, February 19, 2002,
the fourth Nobel Laureate
Lecture will be given by Dr.
David Baltimore, President
of the California
Institute of Technology,
and winner of the
Nobel Prize in biology.
In 1998, the Nobel Committee
recognized Dr. John Hume
and David Trimble for
their contributions
to peace in Northern Ireland.
For more than 30 years,
violence and unrest
based on religious, political,
and social unrest and bias
in Northern Ireland cost
more than 3,500 lives,
and caused untold
horror and pain.
The presence of violence
stunted economic growth,
that fed even more violence.
Throughout this.
period, John Hume
was the most articulate
voice in Northern Ireland's
political leadership
and the struggle
to achieve a just peace.
Dr. Hume started on
the path toward peace
as a leader of the
nonviolent civil rights
movement in the late 1960s.
He went on to establish a
record of community leadership.
He served as a special adviser
to the European Community
Commissioner and
various other groups.
Dr. Hume is presently a member
of the British and European
Parliaments.
Dr. Hume played two important
other critical roles.
He helped to create institutions
in Europe and in Ireland
that respected diversity, such
as the Council of Ministers,
the European Commission,
and the European Parliament.
Drawing on the European
strength, the solidarity
with American and European
peace collaborators,
he was able to bring out
the best among all parties
to create a lasting peace.
Dr. Hume also recognized
the powerful connection
between economic
development and peace,
and is now a champion
for the nation
building that will ultimately
keep conflict under control.
It is fitting, in this
current conflict and outrage
over the tragedy
of September 11,
that we have an opportunity to
have a true soldier of peace
share his views on the
subject the philosophy
of conflict resolution.
It is my distinct honor
and happy privilege
to introduce to you
Nobel Laureate John Hume.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
HUME: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I'm very pleased to be
with you this evening.
"Lift up your faces.
You have a piercing need for
this bright morning dawning
for you.
History, despite its wrenching
pain, cannot be unlived,
and if faced with courage,
need not be lived again."
These are the words of
the poet Maya Angelou.
They are words of hope.
They are words that
should inspire us all,
at this time of great challenge,
that we must never give up
the search for a better world.
In the search for an end
to war and suffering,
and in the search for peace and
justice, we shouldn't give up.
Because we're living
at a very historic time
in the history of the world.
We're living one of
the worst centuries
in the history of the world.
Two world wars.
Millions of people slaughtered.
And, of course,
we're living also
through the biggest
revolution in the history
of the word, the technological,
telecommunications,
and transport revolution.
The world is a much smaller
place in your generation
than it has ever been.
So as we enter in the new
century in a smaller world
and leave behind the
century of two world wars,
let us have our dream,
and work for the dream
that war and conflict
has been left behind,
and that we will be building a
new world in which there will
be total respect for
our common humanity,
and recognize that our
common humanity transcends
our difference.
It's a great
personal honor for me
to be here this evening
at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology to
deliver the Ford Nobel Laureate
Lecture on the theme of
the philosophy of conflict
resolution.
The people of Boston and
the people of Massachusetts,
and indeed wider America, have
been true and very consistent
friends of my
country, of Ireland,
and of our peace process.
Our shared history and ancestry,
along with the very vibrant
connections that exist
today, provides us
all with the inspiration we
need to ensure that we will all
enjoy our future, the
limits which are set only
at the limits of
our own creativity
and our own imagination.
The great city of
Boston has been
a true friend of my
own home town of Derry
through the troubles.
Over the years, we
have made many friends,
and I have made many friends
in that city, whose support
and friendship has been
pivotal as I worked
for economic regeneration
and job creation
as a very central role
of our peace process.
Because central to
my own philosophy,
my own political
philosophy, has always
been the belief that by
making real politics work--
and by real politics
I don't mean
waving flags at one another.
I mean addressing the
real issues of people
and living standards,
of employment,
of education, of
housing, of health care.
That we can change the
dynamic of our society
by concentrating on those,
and transform that society.
All too many young people
from my own city of Derry
and across the north of Ireland
got caught up in paramilitarism
as a consequence of the
crushing unemployment rates that
crippled our prospects
for peace and prosperity,
because they had no
hope, and discrimination
was at the heart of it.
In an effort to address
that particular problem,
I was involved in creating
a project that became
known as Derry-Boston Ventures.
Its purpose was to promote
economic development
between the two cities,
that share so much history.
And with the help of many
of our friends in Boston,
that became a huge
success, leading
to the creation
of many new jobs,
providing many of
our young people
with hope and prosperity.
As I say, real politics.
Indeed, I believe it's
highly appropriate
that the venue for
this speech is here,
because Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
is renowned as one of the
leading lights on the world
stage in education
and technology,
particularly in
this modern smaller
world that I'm talking about.
And given my commitment again
to developing the IT sector
in my home city, I
keep telling my people
that my vision is that the Foyle
Valley, which is our valley,
should become the
Silicon Valley of Europe,
allowing the vast potential of
information and communications
technology to be
fully maximized.
Our city Derry has a
youthful, energetic, and very
well-educated population.
And our university
at Magee College
has one of the best IT centers
of any college in Ireland.
We have a human resource base
there that is second to none,
and I'm determined that its
full potential be fulfilled
as part of our peace process
by working closely with you
people.
And in the intervening
years, of course,
we have developed
Derry-Boston Ventures.
And it's known as the Derry
Investment Initiative.
And I'm very glad that
one of the leading figures
and chief executive of that body
is with me here this evening.
The support of
those real friends
of Derry here in your
part of the world
has been invaluable
as we have worked
to provide and to
foster new opportunity
for our young people.
Today, we are closer
than we've ever
been in Ireland to reversing
the historic tide of immigration
that has brought so many
Irish people to these shores
over many years.
Today, more and more
of our young people
are thankfully growing
up free from violence,
and able to live and work in
the country of their birth.
And today I want to pay tribute
to the people of America
who have stood with us over
those years to get peace,
and whose help is so central
to building our new society
in that new Ireland.
Because your country has been a
rock-solid friend of our peace
process in Northern Ireland,
and continues to be.
The support offered
by United States
has been vital as we work to
leave our conflict behind.
Without the United States,
the peace process might never
have succeeded, and
perhaps we may have never
been able to reach the
historic agreement of Good
Friday in 1998.
For example, our problem,
when you analyze it,
is about three sets
of relationships.
We disagreed about
our relationships
within Northern Ireland, within
Ireland, and between Ireland
and Britain.
Therefore, to solve the problem,
those three relationships
should be the
agenda at any talks.
And that being the
case, the talks
should be conducted
not by one government
but by two governments--
British and Irish governments,
and all the parties
of Northern Ireland.
Now, that's common sense,
and it has happened.
But it took a long time
to get two governments
to agree to work together.
Yet, in 1977, the
first statement
ever made by a president
of the United States
about the Irish problem
was made by Jimmy Carter.
And he was strongly advised
to make this statement
by four people that I'll
talk about in a moment.
But the statement said, called
on the British and Irish
governments to work together to
solve the problem of Northern
Ireland.
And if they did so, they
would get economic support
from America.
Now, that sounds today
a very common sense
and normal statement.
But in 1977, it was a very
revolutionary statement.
And it finally
happened in 1998, when
the two governments
and the parties
could join the table for
the Good Friday Agreement.
But Jimmy Carter was persuaded
to say that by four men
that we called-- that
I worked closely with,
and they were known
as the four horsemen.
Senator Kennedy.
And let me say in this
state that no American has
done more for peace in my
country than your senator.
When I was elected as a
very young man in 1970,
my phone rang.
This is Ted Kennedy.
Could I meet you?
I want to keep briefed
on your problems.
Because that's when the
problems were starting.
We met in Germany.
And from then onwards he
kept in regular contact,
kept himself totally
fully informed,
and took necessary initiatives.
And of course the late
speaker, Tip O'Neill, who
was a great friend of Ireland.
And Hugh Carey of New York,
and Pat Moynihan of New York.
And when the two governments
first got together in 1985
and signed the
Anglo-Irish Agreement,
the following day my phone rang.
Tip O'Neill.
John, we keep our promises--
having been promised
to economically support
the governments if
they came together.
We're setting up the
International Fund for Ireland.
That fund has already
created 38,000 jobs
for our young people in
Northern Ireland and the border
counties.
Thank you, Tip O'Neill
and Ted Kennedy.
Presently, of course, and
given the situation of course
that we're in, that
bringing together
people in the economic
scene is part of what
I call the healing process.
But, as I was saying
at the beginning,
the challenge it now faces
is to leave the conflicts
of past centuries behind us.
And as we enter the new
century and the new millennium,
let us build it as a world of
peace and as regions of peace,
with no conflict.
Because when you have
a look at conflict,
no matter where it is--
and this is me
talking very simply,
but I think it's
also quite profound--
all conflict is about the same
thing no matter where it is.
It's about difference,
whether difference
is your religion, or your
race, or your nationality.
And the message that
we have to get across
and that we have learned
in our part of the world
is that difference is
an accident of birth.
None of us chose to be born.
And we certainly didn't
choose to be born
into any particular community.
There's not two people in
this hall who are the same.
There's not two people in the
whole world who are the same.
Difference is at the
essence of humanity,
and therefore respect
for difference
should be very, very
normal and very common.
But it is the first and
deepest principle of real peace
and real ending of conflict.
And look at our conflict
in Northern Ireland
over the past 30 years.
With a population of
a million and a half,
3,700 people lost their lives or
killed, one out of 450 people.
That's the equivalent
of half a million people
being killed in the United
States in percentage terms.
That's how serious it was.
And, of course, in
addition to that,
over 40,000 people were
maimed and injured.
That's one out of 50 people.
That's the equivalent of 5
million people in the United
States being maimed or injured.
That's how serious
our conflict has been,
and therefore how difficult
it was to bring it to an end.
And it was also necessary
because of that,
in the highest churchgoing
city in Europe, Belfast,
to build walls, up to 12
walls, to separate and protect
one section of a Christian
people from another.
I always described those walls
as an indictment of all of us,
because, as I said, our past
attitudes had built them.
And for that reason, we should
regard them as a challenge
to us, a challenge to
change our past attitudes.
And when you look at our past
attitudes, or our mentalities,
you'll find those
mentalities also exist
in most areas of conflict.
There is the mentality
of the unionist people
in Northern Ireland,
who were largely
the Protestant population.
And I called that the
Afrikaner mindset,
the Afrikaner mentality.
They wished to protect
their identity,
and they rightly wished
to protect their identity
within Ireland.
And I would have no quarrel with
that because it's, as I say,
diversity enriches society.
And therefore it's
right that they should
wish to protect their identity.
My quarrel with them was
their method of protecting it,
the Afrikaner method,
as I called it, holding
all power in their own hands.
In other words, if
you weren't a unionist
in Northern Ireland
when we were growing up,
you had great difficulty.
You never would be in power of
any description in politics,
but you also would have great
difficulty in getting a job,
or getting a house, or
even getting a vote.
Voting was given to
only those people
who paid rates and rents.
And when I would be growing up,
if I had been of voting age,
the only people who would
have votes in the house
would be the father and mother.
And if you owned a company,
a business company,
each business company
had six votes.
And when I was young,
the mayor of Derry
had 43 votes because he owned
seven companies, each of which
had six votes,
plus his own vote.
And, of course, we suffered
terrible discrimination
in jobs and housing.
And although they were
only 30% of the population,
the unionists ruled the city
by a system of gerrymander.
That was the Afrikaner mindset.
Our challenge to that was,
discrimination of that nature
will, in the end,
only lead to conflict,
and it's not the correct way
to protect your identity.
And my challenge to them was,
because of your geography
and your numbers in
Northern Ireland,
the problem can't be
solved without you.
Therefore, come to
the table and reach
an agreement that will
protect your identity forever.
In other words, dialogue.
And dialogue is central to a
peace process in any divided
society.
Then, of course, there
was the mentality
of my own community,
what's called
the nationalist mentality,
or the nationalist mindset.
And, of course, I
challenged that as well.
I called that the
territorial mindset.
Ireland is our land.
Your union is a
minority in our land
and you can't stop us uniting.
And of course there's
a lot of quarrels
in the world about
land and territory.
But my challenge to that mindset
was, look, hold on a minute
here.
It's people that have
rights, not territory.
Without people, even Ireland,
our beautiful Ireland,
is only a jungle.
And when people are divided,
as they are in Ireland,
they can never be brought
together with guns and bombs.
Division can only be
deepened by guns and bombs,
and the problem made far
more difficult to solve.
And, of course, if one
side uses guns and bombs,
the other replies
with guns and bombs.
And, as Martin Luther King and
Mahatma Gandhi kept repeating,
and we did as well, the old
doctrine of an eye for an eye
leaves everybody blind.
Violence, in other
words, had no role
to play in solving our problem.
And, of course, given that we
are a divided people and not
a divided piece of
earth, once again
the only solution is
agreement, and getting together
in dialogue to reach
that agreement.
So the challenge to
both mentalities,
as I have made clear in my
few words recently to you,
was to come to the table
and reach agreement
as to how to share the
piece of earth together.
And, of course,
that wasn't easy.
But we eventually succeeded.
And I have to admit that, in
my work as a political leader
in working for that
agreement and getting
the violence stopped
on our streets,
I was very heavily inspired
by my European experience,
because I'm a member of the
European Parliament, where
I have been since 1979.
And when I first went there--
and I always tell this story--
when I first went to Strasbourg
to a European Parliament
meeting in 1979,
I went for a walk.
And I crossed the
bridge from Strasbourg,
which is in France, to
Kehl, which is in Germany.
And I stopped and I
thought, good lord.
If I had stood in this
bridge 30 years ago,
1949, just after the Second
World War, 35 million people
slaughtered.
And if I had said, don't
worry, it's all over,
and in 20 years' time
we'll have a united Europe.
The quarrel will be
over, and the French
will still be French, and the
Germans will still be German.
I said to myself, if I had
thought that 30 years ago, I
would have been sent
to a psychiatrist.
But it happened.
And the European Union,
when you think of it today,
is the best example in
the history of the world
of conflict resolution.
And for that reason, the
principles and philosophy
at the heart of it
should be studied
by every area of
conflict and brought
to every area of conflict.
And when you look
at the principles,
they're simple and
straightforward.
The first principle, as
I've talked about already,
was respect for difference.
Because what was our wars about?
And respect for difference
is a fundamental principle
of European Union.
No victory for any country.
Second principle.
Creating institutions which
respected those differences,
a council of
ministers which meets,
and there's a minister
from every country.
And no matter how small or large
the country is, none of them
can dominate the others.
They work by agreement.
And the second institution
is the European Commission,
which is a civil service
of European Union, drawn
from all member countries.
And the third is a
European Parliament, drawn
from all member countries.
No victories for any,
but they're all there.
And then the third
principle, which
is the most important
principle of all, which is what
I call the healing process.
They work together in
their common interests,
which was largely economics,
the areas of agreement.
They spilt their sweat,
as I always say, and not
their blood, and
by working together
in their common interests, broke
down the barriers of centuries.
And the new Europe has
evolved, and is still evolving.
And although it only started
out with six countries,
there's now 15 there.
Those same principles
are at the heart
of our agreement of
Good Friday in Ireland,
when you look at it.
Principle number one,
respect for difference.
There was no victory for either
community in our agreement.
Total respect for the
unionist identity.
nationalist identity.
Second principle.
Institutions which
respected those differences.
An assembly elected
to Northern Ireland
by a voting system of
proportional representation,
which ensures that all
sections of the people
are totally democratically
represented.
And then that assembly
proportionally
elects the government
or executive,
and all sections are
represented in the government.
And then the third
principle of course,
which is the most important,
is that our representatives
from all sections
of our community
work together in our common
interests, economic growth.
Spill our sweat, not our blood.
And that's the real
healing process,
working our common
ground together.
And as we do so, as we spill
our sweat and not our blood,
break down the
barriers of centuries
of distrust and prejudice.
And the new Ireland will
evolve in a generation or two
based on agreement and
respect for difference.
And, indeed, I come back to the
importance of the United States
in that healing process area.
Because, given that
the healing process
is working the common
ground together,
the economic development,
wiping out unemployment
and giving real hope
to our young people
that they can earn a living
in the land of their birth,
United States has a very
important role to play in that,
and already are playing it.
So, as I said earlier, when our
four horsemen friends set up
the International
Fund for Ireland.
But, in addition to that,
American investment.
And of course the
marketing of the products
of our small industries
in the United States.
And of course, in
recent times, we've
been very fortunate,
again in my own city,
in attracting major
American investments.
My city is now the European
headquarters of DuPont,
Fruit of the Loom, Seagate,
Stream International.
And under their roofs, young
people from both communities
are working together.
And as they work together,
our dream and hope
is, of course, that
we will break down
the barriers of the past
and that trust will grow,
and the new Ireland will evolve
based on agreement and respect
for difference.
And let me say to you now--
and I'm sure that many of
you have forgotten it--
the philosophy that I am
talking to you about tonight
is a philosophy that you'll
find in your country.
And you will find it summarized
if you pull a cent out
of your pocket and read it.
Because there it is written.
And I learned about it by
studying your history as well.
The three words.
And if you can't, if your
eyesight is not good enough
to read the cent, go to the
grave of Abraham Lincoln,
and there you will
see the message.
"E pluribus unum."
From many we are one.
The essence of our unity is
respect for our diversity.
The real philosophy of peace--
respect for difference.
Look at the whole human race.
As I said earlier, humanity
transcends nationality.
Humanity transcends race
and religion, et cetera.
First and foremost,
we're human beings.
And our common
humanity therefore
demands that we
respect our diversity.
And when I was awarded the
Nobel Peace Prize in '98,
I quoted the Irish poet
William Butler Yeats,
who said, "Too long a sacrifice
can make a stone of the heart,"
if your troubles go on so long.
And there have been times
during the last 30 years
in Northern Ireland when
the search for peace
may have seemed futile.
At the start, a cycle of
violence and counterviolence,
and political failure, that
led to so much devastation
on our streets.
There was despair that
it could never end.
But a well-known Belfast
writer, CS Lewis,
once said that, "Between no
hope and very little hope,
lies a vast ocean
of possibility."
In other words,
always be positive.
Look for the positive
and not the negative.
He was right.
In Northern Ireland, there
always has been hope.
Ordinary people never
lost faith that a new road
could be traveled.
On Good Friday in 1998,
the political parties
of all of the north of Ireland
agreed to walk a new road.
We chose the way of peace, of
partnership, of opportunity.
And the people of Ireland,
north and south, opted
to walk that new
road with us, because
for the first time
in our history--
and this is rather surprising it
was the first time in history--
the people of
Ireland as a whole,
north and south,
spoke as to how they
wish to share the piece
of earth together,
when they came in the joint
referendum, north and south
on the one day, and
overwhelmingly voted
for the Good Friday Agreement.
And that now makes it the
duty of all true democrats
in Ireland to implement
the will of the people.
And those minorities
that are seeking
to overthrow the
agreement are working
against the will of the people.
There's one of them who's a very
leading clerical politician.
And I said to him, Ian, if
you took the word no out
of the English language,
you would be speechless.
And he says, no I wouldn't.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
But in spite of our
progress, today, more than 3
and 1/2 years later, we
appear to have only traveled
a short distance.
But although it is a
short distance, given
our past number of
centuries of conflict,
it's quite a distance.
And that's the nature
of conflict resolution.
There are no easy answers,
or no quick-fix solutions.
It's a tough and
difficult process.
And, of course, as I've said,
it will take the healing process
to complete it.
But we will not give it up.
And we owe it to the
people of our country
and to the wider
world, as I have said,
to keep moving forward.
Because when you have the
divisions of centuries,
as we have and as most
areas of conflict have,
you don't heal them in
a week or a fortnight.
It requires the healing
process, the spilling of sweat
and not of blood,
the working together
in the common interests.
And that's what
we are now doing.
And there's no doubt at all
that our people in Ireland
have set out on an
irreversible course
towards a peaceful future.
The commitment exists to ensure
that we create a future where
everyone can enjoy equal and
fundamental human rights,
where every young Irish
person can find work and enjoy
a good quality of
life, where the pursuit
of our common interest is
the most potent expression
of our shared patriotism.
The fundamental implementation,
therefore, of the Good Friday
Agreement is the vehicle for
delivering that new Ireland,
in which Catholic,
Protestant, and Dissenter will
live together in equality
and respect for diversity.
And the time has now come for
the world as well to learn.
And as I've already said,
and I keep repeating,
because it's a time
to make people think,
I think, that we and you,
you are the generation that
will be leading in the new
century and the new millennium.
So the challenge is to make
sure that your influence is
used to ensure that the entire
world learns that humanity
transcends difference,
that difference is indeed
the very essence of humanity.
Let them learn the fundamental
of your constitution,
"E pluribus unum."
From many we are one.
Its message is very clear,
and it's a powerful message
of peace for the world.
Diversity is a good thing.
Diversity is a healthy thing.
Diversity enriches the world.
No longer can it be
allowed to drive us apart.
allowed to perpetuate
sterile and bloody conflict.
Instead, the true
potential of diversity
must be fostered
as a valuable tool
for bringing people together,
for promoting reconciliation
and developing new and dynamic
relationships between peoples.
In short, as I made clear, no
two human beings are the same,
and humanity is richer
for that difference.
Where would we be, and
what sort of a world
would it be, if we
were all the same?
The answer to difference
is to respect it
and not to fight about
it, to live for ideals,
to live for your country, rather
than to die or kill for it.
And as we begin the
new century, the time
has come for us all to
respect our common humanity.
The time has come for
us all to commit fully
to achieving the end
of all conflict--
because the victims of conflict,
no matter where they are,
are human beings--
and to apply the
basic principles
of conflict resolution
to all areas of conflict.
In short, the time for a
peaceful world has arrived.
In the words of
President John F.
Kennedy, spoken
in 1963 but still
as relevant today as then--
and listen to what he said--
"We can help make the
world safe for diversity.
For in the final analysis,
our most basic common link
is that we all inhabit
this small planet.
We all breathe the same air.
We all cherish our
children's future.
And we are all mortal."
Let us now seek out that
way of peace and justice
for all the world.
And when you think of
those words in 1963
about this small
planet, the planet today
is even much smaller.
Therefore, the challenge that
President Kennedy put to us
is much, much
clearer and stronger.
And let us make it our
dream and our ideal
that the new century
and a new millennium
will be a new century
where e pluribus unum
will be the principle
of the whole world
and the whole planet.
Thank you.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
CLAY: Thank you.
Your speech was very good.
Why don't you just stay and
we'll accept some questions.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
Dr. Hume will accept
some questions.
There are mics in
several places.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Dr. Hume, as a young person from
west Belfast, Northern Ireland,
I'd just like to
take this opportunity
to say thank you to you.
I know that without
your outstanding work
over the last 30 years,
people like myself would never
have had the opportunity to
have a university education,
to have a vote, and
also for me to be
able to say that I count the
daughter of Lord Taylor as one
of my good friends.
However, I'm also
very concerned by
the current political climate
at the moment, the continuing
protests in Ardoyne at the
Catholic school, the breakdown
of the loyalist ceasefires,
and the recent revelation
that unionist politicians
have been speaking
to loyalist paramilitaries,
while at the same time
trying to bring
down the Assembly
and refusing to sit in
power with Sinn Fein.
I'm just wondering
how you perceive
the situation developing
over the next few years.
HUME: Well, as I said earlier,
we have come 3 and 1/2 years,
and it's not as far as we
want to come but we have
made considerable progress.
As I say, the vast
majority of our streets,
there is peace in our
streets and the atmosphere
has been transformed.
But there have been some
recent difficulties.
And one of the
difficulties, of course,
relates to the implementation
of the agreement.
And the point that has
to be made about that,
which I have already
made, is that it
is the will of the people.
That because when the agreement
was reached, my party proposed,
I proposed that the last
word would be with the people
and not with the
politicians, so that nobody,
once the agreement
was put into place,
could then oppose
it and claim they
were acting in the
name of the people.
The people overwhelmingly
voted for it.
Therefore, it's our
duty to implement it.
Therefore, the one area of
controversy at the minute
to be implemented
is what's called
the decommissioning area.
In other words, the paramilitary
organizations like the IRA
should, with the International
Commission General de
Chastelain-- nobody's
asking them to surrender,
but they should show the
International Commission
that their guns have
been put beyond use.
They should do that
as soon as possible,
and that will transform
the atmosphere.
And I hope that they will do so.
Secondly, David
Trimble and company
should not be talking
about withdrawing
from the institutions
like the executive,
as you have said
they are now doing.
Because there again,
what they're doing
is working to bring down the
agreement that the people have
overwhelmingly voted for.
And, of course, there
is also certain elements
in paramilitary
organizations who
are trying to keep
the troubles going.
And north Belfast you mentioned.
And my belief is
that what's happening
there is there are
certain elements
in paramilitary organizations
who don't want law and order
or peace in our streets,
because they want to keep up
their mafia work
in the drugs trade,
and it's not about politics.
And therefore the
whole community
should unite totally and
absolutely against them
in order to get that stopped.
And I know nothing,
strangely enough--
and I'm sure you'll
all agree with me--
I know nothing in
the whole 30 years
in Northern Ireland that got
as much international publicity
as those children
being stopped going
to school in north Belfast.
And when it started,
I was in Strasbourg
at the European Parliament, and
it had never happened before.
But my colleagues from
Germany, and France,
and Spain, and Italy were
all walking up to me.
John, what is wrong?
What sort of people are
that who are stopping
your kids from going to school?
And of course I went on
the radio and television
immediately to
Belfast to say, I'm
speaking to the
Protestant people.
The image that's
going out to the world
is that the Protestant
people are stopping
these children going to school.
And I know that
that is not correct,
because the vast majority
of the Protestant people
are not involved in this.
There's a certain
minority involved.
Therefore I called on the
Protestant church leaders
and politicians to come
out and condemn it.
And they have come out and made
clear their opposition to it.
And we have been
working to get meetings
between the residents
and the schools
to get the matter resolved.
But, as I said, there's those
who are trying to stir it up,
but I hope we will
get it resolved.
But, as I say, when you're
ending centuries of conflict,
you don't get rid
of the distrusts
at the heart of the division
in a week or a fortnight.
It does require the
healing process,
and the framework for
our healing process
are our new institutions,
and we must preserve those.
CURHAN: Mr. Hume, my
name is Jared Curhan.
I'm on the faculty
at the Sloan School,
where I teach negotiation.
I realize this
question may be outside
of your immediate
expertise, but given
that the title of your talk
is the philosophy of conflict
resolution, I wanted to
ask you to comment briefly
on the current situation
between the United States
and the war on terrorism.
Specifically, President
Bush was quoted recently
as rejecting what may or may
not have been a serious offer
by the Taliban for negotiation.
And I'm curious as to what
you think about that stance
and how your three principles
might apply to this conflict.
HUME: Well, first
of all, I think
that the terrible atrocities
committed in New York
and Washington had great
sympathy right across the world
with the American people,
and there's absolutely
no doubt about that.
And I have no doubt
either that there's
strong unity across
the democratic world
that all democratic
governments should
get together with the
United States administration
and to do everything
in their power
to bring to justice
the individuals
and organizations that
committed those atrocities.
But in so doing, to ensure
and to do everything
in their power to ensure that
innocent people don't suffer.
Because that's
one of the dangers
of this type of situation,
that if innocent people suffer,
it creates more recruitment for
the terrorist organizations.
But the other thing that I
would like them to do as well
is to ask for the reasons
why those people did that,
to find out why did they do it.
Because, quite often
in terrorist activity,
the terrorists who
are engaged in it
believe in what
they're doing, even
though everybody else
thinks they're wrong.
For example, to get the violence
stopped in my own country,
I got into direct dialogue
with organizations
that were involved,
even though I totally
condemned what they were doing.
I asked them to state the
reasons for their violence,
and they stated them.
And I said-- well, two reasons.
The British are in Ireland
defending their own interests
by force.
Therefore we have the right
to use force to put them out.
And secondly, they're
preventing the Irish people
from exercising their right
to self-determination.
So I said, look,
reason number one
used to be true in
the past, but it's not
true in today's modern world.
Britain has no economic
or strategic interest
in being in Ireland today.
Our problem is a
legacy of that past.
We're a divided people.
And secondly, the Irish
people, if you describe them
as the people who live
on the island as a whole,
have the right to
self-determination, yes.
But unfortunately
they are divided as
to how to exercise it.
Therefore, it's
agreement we require.
Their reply to me was, you
prove that and we'll chuck it.
We'll stop the violence.
So in my dialogue
with Gerry Adams,
I was asking the British and
Irish governments to make
a declaration which said that.
And they did say it, the
Downing Street Declaration.
In other words, even
though most people
would disagree with the reasons,
then prove to these people
that the reasons
didn't exist anymore.
Now, I don't know, and I have
to admit that I don't fully
understand the situation that
has led to these attacks.
But an attempt should
be made to find out
exactly why did they do it.
And then address those
reasons, as well as--
because no matter what
reason they did it for,
their method of doing
it was appalling,
and the people who died were
totally innocent people.
And therefore they should
be brought to justice,
and their organizations as well.
But, as I say, it would
also be useful to know
why did they do that.
And why did an organized
group of people do that?
What are the reasons?
And address the reasons as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Dr. Hume, I'm very
excited about the idea
you were saying about the
referendum, how that kept
people from co-opting the
process by showing that all
the people were behind it.
Now, the problem
is that last week I
went and heard Paul Simon talk
about the Marshall Plan, which
was behind the,
as you know, some
of the foundations of the EU
and the peace that we've had
in the last 40 years in Europe.
And he said only
18% of Americans
supported the Marshall Plan
when it was implemented.
And he was
particularly concerned
that right now
politicians in America
couldn't go against the general
popular desire, which is not
exactly towards
conflict resolution,
at least not peaceful
conflict resolution.
So I don't know
what my question is.
I like your idea, and I'm
wondering how can you implement
that idea in a general case?
HUME: I don't understand you.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
Could you explain what
you're asking me about?
AUDIENCE: The
question is, do you
think it generalizes that you
can get a popular referendum
to support a peaceful process?
I guess that's
the short version.
HUME: Well, when I was talking
about areas of conflict,
I was talking about
divided communities
in different parts
of the world that are
conflicting with one another.
Like the Middle East is a prime
example of it, for example.
And again it's about territory.
What I'm saying is, first
and foremost, end violence,
because it has no role to
play in solving the problem.
It only deepens the divisions.
Secondly, get into
dialogue and talk
and reach agreement as to how
you share pieces of earth.
And then get the people to
approve of that in referenda.
Then nobody can come out
with a gun and say, oh,
we're sold don't.
We have been sold out.
They can't say that if the
people have voted for it.
And that's why I think that
it's a very powerful element
in a conflict
resolution situation
and in a peace process.
ZAVERI: Hi, my name
is Pedram Zaveri.
I'm a graduate
student here at MIT
and also a native
of Pakistan, which
seems to be a lot in
the news these days.
My question is that,
recently, polls in the US
showed that 92% of
the US population
is behind George Bush,
the political leadership,
in the attacks
that have happened
in the aftermath and
the military action
against the Taliban.
On the other side, 82%
of the Muslim population
in many of the
countries have sort of
thought of Osama bin
Laden, a terrorist,
in some sense as a leader.
Given those kind
of support coming
from the people,
the populations,
how do you see political
leadership, who
thrive on such people,
masses, supporting them,
how can they align
themselves into negotiation?
It almost seems as though people
are happy with the war that's
going on.
They're happy that
there's retaliation,
or they're happy that
a war is developing
and somebody will win.
So how do we move from
such winning the war
and then winning the people over
to a conflict resolution which
may not be totally
supported by people?
HUME: Well, how you do
it is what I've said.
First of all-- and I know that
this is what the people are
supporting--
working to bring to justice
the people who committed
those terrible atrocities.
A vast majority of the
people of the world
support bringing those
people to justice.
But what I'm talking about in
terms of conflict resolution
where you have areas
of the world where
two sections of people
are in conflict, who
live in the same areas,
that their agreement should
go to the people.
Now, what we're talking about
here in the American situation
in relation to those atrocities,
the facts haven't yet emerged.
Therefore, people can't
make up their minds
until the full facts do emerge.
Like, first of all, who exactly
were the people who did this
and why did they do it?
And they certainly have to be
brought to justice for doing it
because there's no justification
of any description for doing
what they did, and they
should be brought to justice.
But if the reasons gave
birth to people like that,
and are likely to continue to
give birth to people like that,
then the reasons should be
addressed as well in order
to demonstrate to people on
the ground in those areas
that those reasons don't exist.
And if there is some bitterness
in those regions arising out
of the past, as we know--
I mean, our quarrel
started in 1689, you know.
And therefore that
could still be there.
While this country has
modernized and gone
on and on and on,
many people would
have forgotten completely
anything that happened
even 20 or 30 years ago.
So what are the reasons
there, is all I'm saying.
I don't know what they are.
I would like to know if there
were reasons and what they are.
Or maybe they were just
traditional religious reasons
from those type of people who
have a very strange notion
about religion.
I don't know what the
reasons were but I would
like to know what they are.
And then when they
are brought forward,
they should be addressed.
CLAY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Dr.
Hume, traditionally
in Northern Ireland,
political power
has grown from people who've
been successful as politicians,
have been successful
because they've
held their ground, because
they've stood firm,
because they haven't changed.
And I'm wondering whether,
in your case, whether you
see the peace process as being
a vindication of a direction
that you chose some time ago
on which you've held firm.
Or have you changed
in your positions?
And if you have changed, what
has that experience been like?
HUME: Well, I
haven't changed much.
I went into politics
to solve problems,
to solve a particular problem.
And in my first
election in 1969,
in my election literature,
which can be read,
I said I was seeking
a mandate to find
a social democratic party,
and I wanted to get away
from the flag-waving politics.
And that the unity
of our country,
which we would
support, could only
come about with the
consent of the majority
of the people in the north.
In other words, it could
only come about by agreement.
Now, we were saying
that in 1969.
At last, 32 years later, the
whole of nationalist Ireland
are now saying the same thing,
but it took a bit of time.
But, also, our
approach to the problem
hasn't changed throughout
our existence as a party.
Because the problem
hadn't changed,
therefore neither did our
approach to solving it.
And our approach to
solving it was based
on our analysis of the problem.
Number one, we're
a divided people,
not a divided piece of earth.
Therefore, we're totally and
absolutely opposed to violence.
Secondly, we're divided on
three sets of relationships,
as I said earlier.
And those should be the
agenda at any talks,
and the two governments
should be working together
to reach agreement
with all the parties.
And thirdly, when
agreement is reached,
it should be approved by the
people and not the politicians.
That was our policy.
It's all on the record
down the 30 years.
We stuck by it and
stuck by it, as I said.
And I kept using the same
language all the time.
They call it Hume-speak
now, you know.
Because I kept saying
the same things.
It's the old pitcher
in me, you know.
When you're out to
persuade people,
you don't persuade them in
one sentence or one speech.
You have to keep at it.
Now, when a man in a pub
uses the language back to me,
I realize, right, I can move
on now and change my language.
But, as I was saying,
we have stood by that.
And the people are aware
that we have done that.
And, as I say, what certain
unionists haven't realized
is that the whole of what's
called nationalist Ireland now
accepts that the
unity of the country
can only come about with
the consent of the majority
of the people of the north,
as well as the majority
of the people of the south.
Divided people, therefore
agreement of sides.
And that's been our consistent
position throughout,
and the people know that.
And, of course,
certain other parties
who felt that the way to
solve the Irish problem
was through violence,
they recognized clearly
that that was completely
wrong, and that the strategy
and tactics of that was
also completely wrong.
And, of course, you
can't be looking
to defend the human
rights of your people
if your method undermines the
most fundamental human right
of all, the right to life.
And therefore, as I say,
I have every confidence
that the people in Ireland
know exactly not only what
we have done to represent them
but that we have stood firm
on our policies and convictions.
CLAY: We have four
people here and they
will be our last questioners.
The first person.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for
speaking this evening.
Earlier in your
speech, you mentioned
that you were very successful
in bringing economic interests
into Ireland, or
gained the promises
for that following
a peace process,
in particular the
International Fund for Ireland.
And you mentioned
briefly that you
had both the very strong
educational background
of your people, and you had
the close ties with America.
And, looking to
generalize that success,
how do you think
other countries where
there are economic
problems that are leading
to the lack of peace, how
can they learn from it
and form some more basis
for a peace process?
HUME: Well, of course,
if they address
the center of their conflict
and they reach agreement,
they then create
the circumstances
where they're working together.
And in many areas of course--
and I was talking about
this earlier today.
In many areas of the world
where there's terrible poverty,
there's also a major
lack of education.
And, as I have said,
when we're sending aid
to third-world
countries, we should also
be making sure that they
get an educational system.
Because the aid can be used in
a week, and then the next week
they're looking for more.
Whereas the real
wealth is its people,
and it's people who create.
And people are far
more equipped to create
when they're educated.
And education-- and this is my
own experience that tells me
this--
is the major factor in
the economic development
of any country.
And therefore it should be
a major factor, particularly
in the third world and
in poorer countries,
getting education
in there to develop.
I mean, in my own
part of the world,
I can see how education
transformed our society.
I was the first generation,
people of my age,
to get educated in
Northern Ireland who
didn't come from a rich family.
My father was
unemployed and I was
the eldest of seven
children, yet I went right
through to university.
Because the very first
year of the new system,
the 11-Plus exam, as it was
called, I got the scholarship.
Before that, there
was no education
available at high school
level or university level
to people whose parents
couldn't afford to pay for it.
That transformed our society.
And if you look at Ireland
today, for the first time
ever the Irish economy
is self-sufficient.
Why?
Because we now have a
total educational system
throughout the whole island.
In other words, once again
coming back to my principle,
respect for humanity.
Human beings are the only
wealth we have in the world.
Make sure that they're,
most are able to create that
by making sure that they're
as fully developed as possible
with their own
skills and talents
through an educational system.
And, indeed, there's nowhere--
and I'm talking there
about normal education,
like going to primary school,
and going to secondary school,
and going to university.
And yet I'm saying
that in a building
where the modernization
of education is fantastic.
And what you're doing--
and I'm talking about
the Institute here--
not only to develop
the skills and talents
in a high-tech world,
but also to create out
there the employment in
this whole new field.
I mean, it's just proving how
societies can be transformed
and what a difference
it can make.
And it's education that's
the first step on the road.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Hume,
it's a great opportunity
to meet somebody like you.
For somebody like me who was
born and have been living
in an area of
conflict for 30 years,
being a Middle Eastern
myself, a Jordanian
from a Palestinian
origin, I really--
we have been all
as Middle Eastern,
I think-- looking at the Irish
experience with great interest.
And having listened
to your principles,
do you think that
resolving conflict
in a situation like Ireland
could be somehow copied
in a case where conflict is
under a situation of occupation
rather than just
division of people?
HUME: Well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HUME: You see, in Ireland
one of the political views
was that a part of the island
was being occupied by Britain.
But what I'm saying
is the principles
at the heart of our agreement
are the exact same principles
that ended conflict between
the peoples of Europe.
We had two world wars.
And when you apply those
principles to the Middle East,
the first message
to get over to them
is that they have
a quarrel, yes.
But the first thing to
learn is that violence
in no shape or form will
solve their quarrel.
It will only make it worse
because people on both sides
will lose their lives.
Therefore, the first
thing they should do
is stop their violence.
And that's common sense.
The second thing
they should then do
is sit down, and talk,
and discuss how they share
the piece of earth together.
Well, you're talking
about occupation,
but how they actually share
the piece of earth together.
And they do it in a manner where
it's people that have rights,
and not territory.
And that's what
I'm talking about
in terms of our agreement,
that the government,
the new government of
Northern Ireland, all sections
of our people, are
in the government
of that piece of earth.
It's people that are
running the piece of earth,
not the piece of earth
running the people.
And the same principle could
apply to the Middle East,
I think, if they just
sit and reach agreement.
Because, once again,
let's not forget
that people were born
in a particular place.
They didn't choose
to be born there.
Other people say, you
shouldn't have been born there.
It should have been me.
But, as I say, that
being the case,
they should agree how they
share a piece of earth,
not the piece of
earth governs them.
Because, as I said
before, what is a piece
of earth if there's no people?
So they shouldn't be
fighting about territory.
They should be agreeing as
to how they live together
in territory.
And, also, of course
I've often said--
and it's been misinterpreted
deliberately by some of my own
political opponents--
we're living in a
post-nationalist world today.
There are those who think
that the nation-state is
an eternal concept.
But before the
nation states, there
were city states, et
cetera, et cetera.
And as the world got smaller,
the nation states grew.
Now, as the world is
getting smaller still,
countries are coming
closer together.
Like in Europe
today, we don't have
independent European countries.
We have interdependent
European countries,
because they're all
working together
in their common interests.
And you take the most
fundamental industry of all--
the industries that
provide your food--
all decisions in agriculture
for 15 of the countries
are taken at European level,
not at national level.
So the world evolves,
and the nation-state
is not an eternal concept.
We've moved beyond it.
But what doesn't change
is that it's people
who are living in the world.
And it's people who
have to live together.
Therefore it's people
who should agree
on how they live
together, not deciding
that one piece of earth
has to get some people out
of it and other people into it.
CLAY: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm concerned that this
country's current reaction
to the tragedies of
September 11 will simply
be part of a cycle of
violence that we've
only just begun to see.
And I'm concerned
that, in reacting
to the events of September
11, we're not seeking justice,
and rather we're seeking
vengeance with violence.
Part of that concern
is due to the fact
that we haven't
paid any attention
to seeking the role
of the United Nations
in seeking justice.
And I was wondering if you could
comment on any potential roles
that the United
Nations could play,
and how we can
strengthen that role
and get the United States
to subscribe to it.
HUME: Well, I've
already spelled out what
I think about that situation.
And as I said, the
people should be
brought to justice, and that
it should be done so in a way
that innocent
people don't suffer.
And it should also
address the reasons.
And another way, of course--
you made a good point there--
that the reasons could
be brought forward fully
and clearly and
objectively would
be if the United Nations
were to go into that area
and find out what was the
reasoning behind all of this,
and explain that and
make their proposals as
to how to ensure that that
sort of thing is not repeated.
CLAY: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Hume,
thank you very
much for coming to speak about
issues of conflict resolution
to the academic community
of the Boston area.
I'm a graduate student
from the Fletcher
School of Law and Diplomacy
just down the road.
You mentioned actors who
attempt to undermine resolution
efforts, and you mentioned
that the people should come out
against such
unrepresentative factions.
But my question is, how do
your principles of conflict
resolution relate to a complex
conflict such as the one
in the Democratic
Republic of Congo,
in which those who have a
vested interest in fueling
a conflict such as a proxy
war for natural resources
are far more powerful and
empowered than those who suffer
from the conflict,
even those who
suffer on both sides of a
conflict that benefits others?
HUME: Well, in areas of
that nature of course,
where you have what
you're talking about,
forms of dictatorship,
et cetera,
that's what the United
Nations are in existence for,
to deal with problems
of that nature.
And the United Nations
should positively
move into areas like that
and describe to the world--
first of all,
describe to the world
the situation that
exists in order
to put pressure on those
who are abusing power,
and create the
process which will
lead to a just
society in such areas.
But, you know, in dealing
with an issue like that,
I would like to study the
whole problem in depth
before, and then come up with
proposals to deal with it.
I was talking in general
terms about areas of conflict
where the conflict is clear
between two communities.
But other areas of
more complicated
stuff that United Nations--
and of course, as I've often
said about the United Nations,
they shouldn't just be sending
armies into areas of conflict.
They should be sending
in a philosophy
as well to solve the problem.
Because normally what happens
in divided societies when
you send an army
onto the streets,
it may stop the violence
but what happens?
In each side they keep getting
more and more guns waiting
for the army to leave.
And therefore they should
be taking in the philosophy.
And I've also been proposing
recently at European level,
at the European
Union, given that it's
the best example in the history
of the world of conflict
resolution.
While it has many departments,
normal departments
of agriculture, et cetera,
and economic departments,
it should also have a department
of peace and reconciliation.
And there should be a
European commissioner
for peace and reconciliation.
And they should take
the philosophy down
into the areas of
conflict and talk
to the different sides
involved, and bring
in the philosophy, not an army.
CLAY: Okay.
Thank you very. much.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]